je crois
oui
répression et condamnations à mort à la
base changement au sommet en chine le
mode rsa aux yankees avaient compris la
révolte des étudiants officiellement
remplacé aujourd'hui par l'ancien maire
de shanghai chargé de conduire le retour
à l'ordre communiste dans tout le pays
elle s'estime mal considérés mal payés
et débordés dans leur travail les
éducatrices et puéricultrices des
crèches parisiennes sont en grève et de
mouvements risquent de s'étendre aux
grandes villes de province c'est déjà le
cas de marseille enquête dans ce journal
sauvons les animaux ce samedi antennes
de l aspa recueille des fonds pour faire
fonctionner des dispensaires spécialisés
destinés aux français qui n'ont pas les
moyens de faire soigner régulièrement
leurs compagnons il ya en france 8
millions de chiens
madame monsieur bonsoir nous commençons
ce journal par trois sujets d'actualité
qui nous concerne pratiquement tous et
de très près d'abord la garde de nos
enfants lorsque dans un couple mari et
femme travaille depuis une semaine les
éducatrices et puéricultrice des crèches
parisiennes sont en grève pour réclamer
de meilleures conditions de travail une
meilleure reconnaissance de leur
profession et des augmentations de leurs
salaires et leurs collègues de province
sont en passe de les rejoindre comme par
exemple à marseille où elles seront en
grève à partir de lundi à paris ce matin
des mères de famille avait décidé de
soutenir l'action des personnels des
crèches en manifestant à leur manière en
quête d' allah nous beschi et christian
l'eau ce matin des couches culottes
usagées volées parfois très bas en
direction des forces de l'ordre
un coup de main donné aux personnels des
crèches par les parents en colère
elles ont raison de demander ce qu'elle
demande c'est pour le confort et la
sécurité de nos enfants ce qu'elle
demande
on est en colère contre la mairie de
paris et le gouvernement qui se
renvoient la balle qui ne veulent pas
négocier ça fait presque trois semaines
et on se demande ce qu'il fasse il faut
savoir que les crèches parisiennes
dépendent de la mairie toutes les autres
du ministère de la fonction publique ou
une réunion doit avoir lieu le 5 juillet
à propos des salaires
la ville de paris attend elle s'alignera
sur les propositions du ministère
côté salariés on reste déterminés sont
tout d'abord des revendications
salariales
le personnel de la petite enfance et un
personnel sous payés alors qu'il a une
valeur éducative importante
c'est notre seule revendication non ce
n'est pas la seule revendication nous
demandons si une réorganisation des
services notamment au niveau des
effectifs de remplacement des congés au
niveau des formations au niveau des
évolutions de carrière
la mairie de paris nous propose
actuellement des négociations sur
l'organisation du travail
en fait
nous nous voulons tout négocier parce
que lorsqu on reconnaîtra nos statuts et
que l'on verra
honnêtement on reconnaîtra aussi notre
profession environ un millier d'employés
des crèches parisiennes sur les trois
mille que compte globalement la capitale
était présenté hier à l'assemblée
générale parmi elles des éducatrices
salaires de début 5600 francs niveau bac
+ 2 ans d'études dépit riklis 6200
francs
bac + 4 points des pulls les
augmentations demandées varie entre 300
francs pour les débutantes et 1000
francs en fin de carrière
deuxième sujet de préoccupation très
proche de nous la pollution des côtes
françaises avec une initiative généreuse
menée au large de cannes en méditerranée
dont les eaux sont menacés de mort par
asphyxie dans la mesure où les herbes
qui poussent au fond de l'eau et qui
fournissent l'oxygène indispensable à la
vie sous marine sont en voie de
disparition
un groupe de bénévoles a donc décidé de
repiquer cm un véritable travail de
titan
reportage de patrick esther et même
ailleurs à quelques centaines de mètres
de la côte dans cette zone où la lumière
peut encore traverser l'eau les fonds de
la méditerranée sont bordées par une
forêt constitué de possibles honni des
plantes qui existe depuis des centaines
de millions d'années et qui ont permis à
la vie d'exister dans cette mer
aujourd'hui ces herbiers se meurt
victime de la pollution engrais
détergents pesticides les victimes
également de l'aménagement de nouveaux
ports qui modifie les courants et
perturbe les fonds
ni apporte énormément d'oxygène donc si
elle disparaît il ya plus d'oxygène
c'est l'équivalent de la forêt sur la
tête et donc la perte d'oxygène signifie
que le poisson qu'il n'y a plus de vie
dans cette franchise orale qui est très
étroite et il faut absolument préserver
dès 1972 un marin pêcheur george cooper
avait eu l'idée de reproduire ces
plantes un aquarium puis de les
replanter en mer en les accrochant sur
des carrés de béton son association
constituée de bénévoles ainsi
réimplanter 85000 mouture il devient
pourtant urgent de passer la vitesse
supérieure car sinisant suffisent pour
faire disparaître une forêt de possibles
ni il faut 40 ans pour reformer une
touffe de trois mètres de diamètre à
partir d'une mouture l'université de
nice l'institut français de recherche
ifremer
la lyonnaise des eaux intensifie
maintenant les recherches pour mieux
comprendre ces phénomènes de destruction
et voir comment assurer la meilleure
reprise possible aux boutures
tout est affaire tout est à inventer
c'est l'agriculture sous marine et donc
nous faisons des multiples expériences
savoir quelle est la meilleure façon de
faire pousser ses plantes sous marines
est particulière vrai
80 % des poissons de la méditerranée
vivent et se reproduisent grâce à la
possible ni river de cette plante la
méditerranée devienne vrai un désert
troisième sujet de préoccupation à la
veille des premiers départs en vacances
du mois de juillet malheureusement
revoici les traditionnels incendie de
l'été en corse dans le midi et en
bretagne sécheresse mistral malveillance
les trois raisons de ces incendies
reportage d'agnès poirier les jean
françois georges et l'été commence à
peine mais déjà les premières alertes au
feu
hier six incendies se sont déclarés dans
les bouches-du-rhône et le var quatre en
corse
ici à callas dans la région
d'aix-en-provence tout l'après midi 300
pompiers ont lutté contre les flammes
avec des camions pompes et les canadairs
bilan 100 hectares dévastés depuis le
début de l'année de 5000 hectares ont
déjà brûlé c'est plus que pour toute
l'année dernière responsable le mistral
les incendies ne se déclenche que les
jours de grand vent mais surtout la
sécheresse
il n'a pas véritablement plus depuis le
mois d'avril et la végétation et déjà
sèches comme au mois d'août
nous sommes dans une zone rouge dans une
situation difficile et il faut que la
population comprenne très bien que par
ses par ces chaleurs et c'est bon
n'importe quel feu peut devenir
rapidement une catastrophe donc les
risques
le feu est important il faut la plus
grande prudence pas jeter de mégots pas
faire de feu pas
en fait tout ce qu'il peut provoquer un
incendie doit être abolie et les gens
doivent avoir conscience que le moindre
feu la moindre étincelle peut provoquer
une catastrophe dans ces régions ici au
cirque osc responsable des interventions
contre le feu pour tout le midi de la
france on ne cache pas son inquiétude
bien sûr des canadairs survol en
permanence la région et peuvent ainsi
intervenir quelques minutes après la
détection d'un syndic
mais faute de météo en grève à marseille
depuis un mois on ne peut faire aucune
prévision
seule certitude pour les pompiers du
midi de la france aussi l'été sera chaud
l'actualité à l'étranger maintenant
répression et condamnations à mort pour
les manifestants du mois de mai en chine
mais aussi changement de tête au sommet
de l'état avec la nomination d'un
nouveau secrétaire général du parti
communiste chinois
l'homme qui remplace monsieur à audience
jugé trop modéré vis-à-vis des étudiants
dont il avait compris la révolte se
nomme qui hante ses mines ancien maire
de la principale ville du pays
shanghai il doit incarner le retour à
l'ordre communiste jérôme benest change
de mines
le tombeur de zhao ziyang réformateur
mais avec une prudence presque féline en
suivant le courant toujours à l'ombre du
languedoc ling ji dont la vieille garde
semble aujourd'hui triomphé de sa
résidence de shanghai tang a répondu à
une interview de la télé question
yougoslave en 81 cents alors qu'il est
encore maire de la vitrine de la chine
mais la victoire de zinc
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas cet apparatchik
police et au profil bas dont on ne sait
pas combien de temps il pourra rester à
la tête du parti ce nom
la victoire des conservateurs c'est la
belle unanimité avec laquelle les
membres du comité central
enfin réunis on votait l'éviction de son
prédécesseur
zhao ziyang accusé d'avoir soutenu le
mouvement contre-révolutionnaire des
étudiants ici le 19 mai il s'excuse
auprès d'eux d'être arrivé trop tard il
sait que dans quelques heures sera
proclamé la loi martiale tient son
successeur lui fut le premier haut
dignitaire régional du parti a approuvé
publiquement cette fois marche
changement de tête au sommet de l'état
en chine répression et condamnations à
mort pour les manifestants du mois de
mai à la base
bien qu'elle soit sans influence sur les
dirigeants chinois et bien les
manifestations de soutien se poursuivent
à on compte tout d'abord aujourd'hui où
vous teniez ou vite une importante
colonie chinoise
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes ont défilé dans les défilés
également à paris en signe de solidarité
reportage de valérie fournioux et
frédéric basque
un rassemblement pour ne pas oublier
pékin et les étudiants de la place
tiananmen
comme c'est bien exécuté il ya deux
jours un rassemblement pour que cela ne
se reproduise plus plusieurs
personnalités politiques syndicales et
artistique
barbara hendricks mad as many end et
leurs symboles le même que celui des
étudiants de pékin
la déesse de la démocratie cette statue
détruites par l'armée chinoise après le
massacre de la nuit du 3 juin bas dans
les yeux encore une image ainsi pour par
celle d'un étudiant les mains nues
kkr est une colonne de temps nous avons
appris que cet étudiant été exécuté
sommairement sans procès d'une balle
dans la nuque
voilà ce qui est intolérable ce quelle
horreur ce qui est inacceptable
cet étudiant ce martyr est le symbole
même maintenant de la révolution
chinoise elle des étudiants est celle de
la liberté de l'abbé style la
manifestation s'est dirigé vers la place
de la république
les slogans liberté et démocratie malgré
les menaces et la peur certains osent
parler à visage découvert on devait se
mobiliser procédé fait parce que c'est
contre eux tu étais donne au mieux pour
trouver de ses villas c'est le minimum
qu'on demande
ils défendent toute la vérité à l'envers
alors les gens même du pays croient que
les arabes les étudiants du pékin qui
était sur la place tiananmen était des
contre-révolutionnaires camille 10 à la
télé sur la télé gimont nous sommes très
déçus
nous parce que le gouvernement a fait du
peuple chinois un bouc émissaire de
leurs pouvoirs de leurs fiers de pouvoir
au total plus de 3000 personnes venue
demander l'arrêt immédiat des exécutions
continuer ce qu'il est maintenant
impossible de faire en chine réclamer la
démocratie la politique française c'est
aujourd'hui essentiellement la réunion
des rénovateurs à lyon avec en parallèle
une mésaventure survenue à quatre
d'entre eux voyagent entre dans un petit
avion privé
une panne de moteur survenu au-dessus de
la ville les a obligés à atterrir en
catastrophe en plein centre ville sur la
saône heureusement plus de peur que de
mal tout le monde en est sorti indemne
et à peine oui
quant à la réunion elle-même et bien
elle a eu lieu à l'hôtel de ville de
lyon dans le fief du nouveau maire
michel noir quelque peu refroidi par le
succès de la liste européenne rpr udf
emmenée par l'ancien président giscard
d'estaing dimanche dernier eh bien les
rénovateurs de l'opposition ont tout de
même maintenu leur idée de créer un
groupe unique de l'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale
contrairement à ce que souhaite monsieur
chirac et les centristes des rénovateurs
persévère donc mais il ne fixe plus de
date pour réaliser leurs ambitions
reportage nos envoyés spéciaux gilles
leclerc et jean françois bernier
il ya trois mois la rénovation à droite
démarrons font pas la jeune génération
bouscule le jeu classique des partis de
l'opposition
mais manque le rendez vous de l'élection
européenne
mais à la veille de l'été la course de
vitesse à la rénovation a cette fois qui
a commencé de valéry giscard d'estaing à
françois léotard en passant par jacques
chirac et sa jeune garde tous la semaine
dernière prenne des initiatives à
l'intérieur des appareils les idées des
rénovateurs sont désormais reprises par
les aînés reste alors à reprendre le
dessus et à se persuader qu'on est
toujours présent malgré peut-être les
différentes analyses entre philippe
seguin et les autres sur la nécessité ou
non d'appeler la constitution d'un grand
parking paul hommes politiques hauts
responsables plus attachée au
patriotisme de son parti qu à cet
impératif catégorique de l'union et de
la rénovation par la constitution d'une
formation commune pourra préférer le
surplace voire même de faire obstacle à
cette volonté en toute amitié nous en
prendrons acte mais ceci ne nous ne nous
écarterons pas de l'objectif à atteindre
chacun décline la rénovation à sa façon
aux besoins même en jouant sur les mots
lors sera ce un jour parce que c'est une
façon pour certains de poser le problème
la fusion sera ce autre chose je dirais
volontiers à la limite
qu'importe mais en attendant des jours
meilleurs les douze préfère aujourd'hui
au moins se féliciter d'avoir fait
bouger l'opposition le serment de lyon
conclut aujourd'hui se traduit d'abord
par un manifeste adopté à l'unanimité
réclamant l'union et l'organisation d'un
nouveau paysage politique français à
droite tendant à la formation d'une
seule composante un moyen d'exister et
de serrer les rangs
alors qu'aucun rendez vous électoral
majeur n'est fixée avant trois ans la
volonté existe on a pu le voir
aujourd'hui mais le pari restera bien
difficile puis encore le parti des
écologistes français réunis ce week end
à saint denis dans la banlieue
parisienne a décidé d'entreprendre des
négociations avec ses principaux
partenaires européens
les verts allemands pour former un
groupe unique à l'assemblée européenne
de strass
pour négociation qui s'annonce difficile
dans la mesure où les écologistes
allemands sont beaucoup plus politisé
que les français est très marqué à
gauche voire à l'extrême les problèmes
du logement la loi méhaignerie a
finalement la vie beaucoup plus dur
qu'on aurait pu le penser en effet à
l'occasion du congrès des promoteurs et
constructeurs privés le ministre du
logement monsieur besson a annoncé que
contrairement à ce qu'avaient demandé
les socialistes à leur retour au pouvoir
eh bien les avantages fiscaux attribue
aux particuliers qui investissent dans
l'immobilier de location ne seront pas
supprimées au contraire même eh bien ces
avantages vont être renforcés car
l'investissement privé est indispensable
au maintien du rythme de la construction
en france en quête de gens payent eux et
pierre issa serge cadre commercial
parisien christian vgr vient d'acheter
un appartement destiné à la location
c'est son premier investissement
immobilier il a pris un deux pièces
payer un million cinq cent mille les
logements ici long du studio au 5 pièces
christian bégin n'avait plus sa place et
mais il a volontairement restreint son
achat l'avantagé fiscal étant limité à
40 mille francs compte tenu de delà de
la réglementation
je ne pouvait déduire que que ce maximum
en 89
donc aucun intérêt à l intérêt à
acquérir un appartement plus important
si l'opportunité se présentait par
exemple l'année prochaine je pense que
je
je me porterait acquéreur d'un autre
appartement et si possible plus
important l'investissement privé dans
les grands logements pourraient se
développer bientôt si le gouvernement
suit les professionnels qui demandent
que la réduction d'impôt actuellement de
40 mille francs par ménage soit portée à
80 mille francs mais étalée sur deux ans
la réduction équivaut à 10 % de
l'investissement plafonné à 400 mille
francs ce qui conduit à l'achat de deux
pièces montées le plafond à 800000
francs permettrait l'achat de logements
de quatre pièces des loyers notamment à
paris sont chers petits ou grands
logements mais on trouve aujourd'hui à
louer des studios et les deux pièces
alors qu'ils étaient rares avant les
avantages fiscaux ce qui est rare
aujourd'hui c'est le grand logement du 3
au 5 pièces parce qu on en construit
pratiquement plus d'où la mesure demande
repose sur l'épargné privée puisque
chacun sait que le financement public ne
niera jamais plus loin qu'il ne va
maintenant il ira plutôt de façon
dégressive
donc c'est une mesures compensatrices et
je crois c'est une façon de maintenir
l'activité économique hérité du bâtiment
c'est grâce en effet aux investisseurs
vingt mille logements l'an dernier que
le chiffre de 300 mille logements neufs
a été maintenu après avoir donné
satisfaction locataires et à la gauche
en encadrant les loyers
le gouvernement socialiste ne peut que
se montrer aimable avec les
propriétaires privés
un réalisme qui lui ferait gagner
parents quelques dix mille logements
locatifs supplémentaires la pollution
après le pétrolier exxon valdez
souvenez-vous au large de l'alaska
nouvelle menace de marée noire sur la
côte est des états unis menace moins
graves mais réelle tout de même un
pétrolier grec s'est échoué hier soir
avec à son bord 29 millions de litres de
mazout
mais à la différence de l'exxon valdez
il apparaît que cette fois ci est le
président des états unis monsieur bush
lui-même ayant été aussitôt alerté bien
les secours ont été très rapidement
acheminée sur place marc maisonneuve
partie de la mer noire le workflow dj un
pétrolier battant pavillon grec convoi
près de 29 millions de litres de mazout
lorsqu'il s'est échoué au large de rhode
island tout près de la côte nord-est des
îles
unis une nappe de mazout de 8 km de long
recouvre la mer le bâtiment est rentré
en deux endroits n'est qu'à 5 km de
braintree très vite les secours
interviennent des barrages flottants
sont mises en place des pompes
aspirantes qu'on permette de remettre à
flot le bateau empêchant ainsi que le
pétrole n'atteigne newport véritable nid
de milliardaires américains en alaska
l'exxon valdez remis à flot le
supertanker nord américain à l'origine
d'une des plus grande catastrophe
écologique qu'aient connu les usa 40
millions de litres de brut s'étaient
échappés de ses flancs retourne en
californie ce bâtiment d'une longueur de
300 mètres
doit-il être entièrement reconditionné
ces travaux dureront neuf mois au moins
et on s'attend à ce que cela coûte
plusieurs millions de dollars
et puis cette dépêche datée de 19h30 et
qui nous annonce une deuxième marée
noire en 24 heures sur la côte est
américaine cette fois ci c'est un
pétrolier d'origine uruguayenne qui se
serait échoué sur la côte est des états
unis avec à son bord 72 millions de
litres de mazout au terrible paradis des
producteurs de drogue en colombie la
police vient d'effectuer une opération
de commando très spectaculaire dans
plusieurs laboratoires et entrepôt
réduisant à néant un stock très
important de cocaïne
rémy roche ils appartiennent à une force
d'élite de la police colombienne mission
livrer une guerre sans merci aux
trafiquants de drogue
ici dans la région de medellin la plus
importante zone de production de cocaïne
du monde
quelques mines d'abord pour rendre
inutilisables cette ancienne route
aménagée en piste d'atterrissage
au bout le laboratoire de transformation
mystérieusement déserté à l'arrivée du
commando à l'intérieur tout ce qu'il
faut pour produire la drogue dit ricane
des terres d'acétone des fours à
micro-ondes
tout doit être détruit par dizaines des
bidons remplis de cocaïne
ils doivent aussi disparaître foot feu
pour incendier le tout quelques dernière
rafale en quittant les lieux la semaine
dernière au cours de cette opération
rainbow 10 laboratoires sont ainsi
partis en fumée il produisait plus d'une
tonne de cocaïne par jour
on passe du coq à l'âne et ça tombe bien
puisqu'il s'agit d'animaux tout au long
de ce samedi sur antenne 2 vous avez pu
suivre et vous allez encore suivre
l'opération sauvons les animaux engagés
aux côtés de la spa il s'agit en fait de
trouver les fonds nécessaires pour faire
fonctionner des dispensaires pour
animaux ou pourront se rendre tous ceux
qui n'ont pas forcément les moyens
suffisants pour faire correctement
soigné leur compagne il faut rappeler un
chiffre je crois on comptabilise en
france plus de 8 millions de chiens en
quête de marque maisonneuve et jean
louis goût serre
liévin une petite ville du nord de la
france ici la mine a fait vivre et
mourir plusieurs générations l'arrêt des
pluies la crise vont contribuer à créer
une zone urbaine où la vie n'est pas
facile pour les plus démunis
pour ceux qui ont tout juste
l'indispensable malgré une vie de
travail
avoir un animal est un réconfort
quotidien
paraît pas être un luxe d'avoir un chien
un luxe ah non pour moi aussi la lutte
non plus disons c'est la plaisir pour
cette compagnie donc on peut pas faire
franchir la maison sur une feinte au
panier ou la faute enfants ça nous
ferait à coup de pierres quand même pour
les nourrir votre tuellement presque six
ans comme nous un immense courage il
manque un petit constructeur simon sur
deux tendances comme nourrit l'autre on
tombe alors à sa place à la maison comme
à gauche mais pourtant impossible de
payer un vétérinaire traditionnel un
bisou rencontrerez paille
l'ancien milieu de gens au chômage
d'anciens beaucoup de ressources à
l'intérieur de ce dispensaire de la sp.a
gratuitement des vétérinaires tattoo
vaccine soigne des chiens ou des chats
surtout il les stérilisent afin d'éviter
leur prolifération limitant aussi le
nombre d abondance grâce au dispensaire
ceux qui n'ont pas assez d'argent pour
assumer des traitements onéreux garde un
animal en bonne santé et un dispensaire
pour que ceux qui désiraient l'animal et
qui ont parfaitement droit à la
tendresse canal
puisse la voir à liévin comme dans
quatre autres villes de france
rouen amiens lyon et paris des
dispensaires sp.a ont été créés il donne
aux possesseurs d'animaux domestiques
l'assurance de trouver la compétence
qu'il faut pour soigner leurs compagnons
une compétence qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens de s'offrir et qui ne peut être
l'apanage d'une poignée de nantis
en france il y a un animal dans un foyer
sur deux
oui et pour autant ces animaux qu'une
majorité de français donc m et adopte
comme compagnon de vie ne sont pas sans
provoquer des nuisances il est aussi
honnête de le souligner nuisances et
risques de maladie qui coûte cher à la
collectivité au point que régulièrement
dans les grandes villes est bien la
menace est brandie d'une taxe pour les
propriétaires de chiens et à ses animaux
domestiques et bien il faut ajouter
certains oiseaux comme les pigeons en
quête de josé blanc lapierre et roger
moore sous 10 heures de face à des
porteurs de maladies aux etats unis les
pigeons s'appelle les rats volants paris
les aime mes limites leur nombre pause
d'aiguilhe dissuasive amende de 800
francs pour les nourrir sur la voie
publique distribution deux fois par an
de graines contraceptive ils ne seraient
plus que quarante mille aujourd'hui pour
en arriver là voici la méthode
ces coups de filet ont lieu tous les
jours les pigeons malades sont éliminés
les autres sont paraît-il relâché même
problème avec les chats errants risques
de maladies et prolifération
incontrôlable dans le cimetière de
montmartre ils sont 250 la mairie ferme
les yeux sur l'association qui les
nourrit chaque jour et transformé
tombant litière mais quand le nombre de
plaintes s'accélère la fourrure fait une
descente cap sur les malades et les
livres à la spa pour gérer les animaux
de la ville beaucoup de diplomatie
s'impose
je crois si vous voulez qu'un autre
manière ferme mais nous coercitif au
sens agressions des bêtes
nous essayons de gouverner c'est à dire
de fait les deux parties car vous avez
exactement à paris ces conventions de
gens qui sont pour la présence des bêtes
à paris et vous avez fait comme pour 102
ans de gens qui se plaignent des crottes
de chien si beau si le même qu'on ne
peut pas arbitré par le nord 19h50 la
horde des yamaha verte phare à l'assaut
des trottoirs parisiens mission le
ramassage des crottes de chien distance
nettoyer 3000 km par jour
coût 35 millions de francs par an mais
ce dispositif reste insuffisant pour les
250 mille chiens avec propriétaire
recensés à paris
les décrochages sur les trottoirs sont à
l'essai à la rentrée un code du chien en
ville sera imposée l'âge d'or de
l'automobile de compétition c'était
entre 1930 en micro 1930 pardon et les
années de l'après deuxième guerre
mondiale ce week-end sur l'historique
circuit de montlhéry dans la grande
banlieue parisienne tous les amateurs et
ceux qui aiment les belles choses
pourront admirer ces voitures qui nous
ont fait rêver présenté par des équipes
qui tout au long de l'année récupère une
pièce ici ou là pour que roule à nouveau
ses magnifiques machines en portage de
tyrie calmette et bernhard wehrli
un autre vitesse de montlhéry austin
healey avec des yeux de crapauds la mini
cooper atteint les images tournées hier
mais hier matin pas en 1969 pour couvrir
avec des voitures d'époque de
compétition réussie il faut d'abord
trouver l'épave et la restaurer puis
effectuer la préparation course à
l'identique
tout se passe ici dans un petit garage
de la banlieue parisienne il ne reste
que quelques heures avant les essais de
montlhéry ambiance tendue car lorsque
les adultes s'amusent avec leurs jouets
tout devient très sérieux qui avait 17
18 ans dans les années 65
maintenant je trouve avec avoir 35 entre
35 et 40 ans qui sont assis socialement
ils ont envie de se faire plaisir et je
crains c'est vraiment un bon palliatif
pour rentrer dans la compétition
automobile sans justement rentrer dans
la moderne qui est très fort
aux coupes de l'âge d'or quelques
privilégiés les écuries presque officiel
comme ferrari bien sûr
les 300 autres concurrents sont souvent
propriétaires de leur bulle
du garagiste aux cadres supérieurs tous
partagent la même passion et pour se
faire aider
on recrute tout azimut parmi les pilotes
du team 60
on trouve aussi bien un jeune très
célèbre venu pour donner un coup de main
mais aussi pour s'amuser que la propre
femme de l'animateur
aucune idée de ce que vous ma voiture
dans laquelle un gourmand tout cas bon
bah je vais essayer je vais faire le
maximum
c'est la première fois que vous la
prenez cette voiture c'est la première
fois qu'ils pensent être battue est sa
première en question de sortir du
problème
rim a bien eu des trois programmes et
j'étais pas vraiment passionné en bonne
épouse l'accompagné pendant trois ans et
puis je me suis trouvé un peu je
m'ennuyais ça les a cueillies donc je me
suis dit ah koon et maintenant je n'ai
fait qu'une course cette année ça me
manque mais l'âge d'or demeure
essentiellement masculin vivre pour de
vrai les jeux de la cour de récréation
depuis sa propre branche sur des joies
diana et on a toujours été un peu gamme
des gamins qui à 200 à l'heure dans une
lotus seven se font parfois très peur
mais on veut c'est les accidents graves
sont très rares
et le bricolage se prolonge jusqu'au
dernier moment pour arriver à la
perfection sensualité émotions on en
oublierait presque de concourir
il faut que je coure demain après demain
oui on va essayer c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs depuis deux ans que j'ai
bloqué les durites elle est devenue ce
qu'elle est devenue
ces marques de moins en moins point
savez la france les coupes de l'âge d'or
attire chaque année des dizaines de
milliers de spectateurs supplémentaires
un peu pour le fait son esthétique
beaucoup pour la nostalgie pour revivre
l'époque où l'automobile c'était d'abord
un plaisir sur deux roues seulement
maintenant cet après midi à montluçon
victoire d' eric caritoux dans le
championnat de france cycliste
professionnel le champion n'a pas eu à
endosser le maillot tricolore puisqu'il
l'avait déjà remporté la compétition
l'année dernière tout redémarre il est
en forme laurent fignon après sa superbe
victoire en italie
c'est le favori de ces championnats de
france c'est d'ailleurs lui qui va
ramener le peloton sur toutes les
échappées sur tout sauf sur la dernière
on y retrouve boyer c'est lui qui la
provoquent dans les 20 derniers
kilomètres
gayant rue et gagne peut lier caritoux
bezos le claire jourdan et l'avenue
fignon et c'est bien de réagir ils
démarrent tout seul mais ne reviendra
pas cette fois les dix hommes comptent
rapidement 30 secondes 45 secondes puis
une 30 d'avancé sur le peloton à cinq
kilomètres de l'arrivée
on se prépare alors au sprint mais dans
le dernier kilomètre des zoé caritoux
parviennent à s'extraire
bezos l'espoir numéro 1 caritoux le
champion de france en titre caritoux qui
restent jusqu'à 300 mètres de la ligne
dans la roue de bezos et puis qui
démarre il existe nous
au classement final eric caritoux
l'emportent donc et réalise le doublé 2e
laurent bezeau troisième martial gayant
à 14 secondes
une autre arrivée maintenant à quatre
pattes celle là il s'agit du tiercé du
quarté + qui se courait cet après midi à
longchamp pour gagner il fallait jouer
le 4 le 2 et le 12 p'tit tiercé 750
francs pour ce qui concerne le quarté +
vous ajoutez le 5 et vous gagnez 3700
francs et 80 centimes voilà ce journal
est terminée tout de suite après bien
entendu les prévisions météo avec josé
dans la pierre suivie d'un champs
elysées spéciales belges ne ce n'est pas
une blague aux alentours de zéro heure 0
heure 5
eh bien vous retrouverez jean-claude
allanic pour les toutes dernières
informations de ce samedi
quant à moi je vous dit bonsoir
excellente soirée sur notre chaîne et à
demain 13h
au jeu
et
urgent à la tête du pc chinois le
secrétaire général zia aux yankees
étaient favorables aux réformes a été
remplacé par l'ancien maire de shanghai
zhang hemin à lyon les rénovateurs
propose la formation d'un groupe unique
de l'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
mais ils ont évité de jeter de l'huile
sur le feu deuxième maillot tricolore
pour eric caritoux il a remporté cette
année encore le championnat de france de
cyclisme professionnel à montluçon
bonsoir nous développerons ses titres
dans quelques instants mais pour
commencer le drame de celle qu'on
appelle les mères d'alger il s'agit de
français ayant épousé des algériens de
part et d'autre de la méditerranée
on se dispute les enfants treize maires
ont pris l'avion ce soir une nouvelle
fois pour alger le reportage de valérie
fournioux et de françois hollande esman
les mères d'alger
voilà non qu'elle étende une visite un
sourire mais celui de leurs enfants
la barre rester avec leur père en
algérie ce soir elles ont choisi de
partir certaines sans visa pour tenter
l'impossible l'interdît
demandez gosier un geste humanitaire
pour permettre à des enfants de venir
cet effet puisqu'en principaux fai
redeviendrez malgré les efforts de la
commission qui a examiné
pratiquement tous les dossiers tant que
les procédures juridiques ne sont pas
terminées les enfants ne faudra pas
venir dans le cadre du transfrontières
le dossier de jocelyne celui de son fils
qu'elle n'a pas vu depuis un an s'enlise
dans les procédures comme 80% des
dossiers depuis la convention
franco-algérienne de juin 88
seuls 37 cas ont pu être définitivement
réglé lui à orly pour essayer de leur
faire comprendre que leur dossier était
sur la bonne voie et que si je comprends
leur douleur
je crois que leur action est plus
affective peut raisonner qu'elle demande
à ne pas quelque chose de politique de
juridique elle demanda geste humanitaire
ce qui n'est pas la même chose
les dossiers et les frontières sont des
choses bien théorique par rapport à des
déchirements des maires par rapport aux
enfants qui ne sont pas retrace à bhl
dans des papiers presse femmes qui
expriment leurs souffrances le désir de
revoir leurs enfants cet été pour les
vacances un droit qu'elle renégocie
imperturbablement chaque année en chine
à ausy angle secrétaire général qui
dirigeait le parti communiste pendant la
révolte de la place tienanmen à payer
pour son indulgence à l'égard des
étudiants
il a été limogé et remplacé par l'ancien
maire de shanghai yang et mines jérôme
baugnies chances de mines
le tombeur de zhao ziyang réformateur
mais avec une prudence presque féline en
suivant le courant toujours à l'ombre du
dan zhang ping dont la vieille garde
semble aujourd'hui triomphé de sa
résidence de shanghai yang a répondu à
une interview de la télévision
yougoslave en 81 cents alors qu'il est
encore maire de là
vitrine de la chine mais la victoire de
dingue aujourd'hui ce n'est pas cet
apparatchik police et au profil bas dont
on ne sait pas combien de temps il
pourra rester à la tête du parti
non la victoire des conservateurs c'est
la belle unanimité avec laquelle les
membres du comité central
enfin réunis on votait l'éviction de son
prédécesseur
zhao ziyang accusé d'avoir soutenu le
mouvement contre-révolutionnaire des
étudiants ici le 19 mai il s'excuse
auprès d'eux d'être arrivé trop tard il
sait que dans quelques heures sera
proclamé la loi martiale tient son
successeur lui fut le premier haut
dignitaire régional du parti a approuvé
publiquement cette fois marche
et puis manifestation cet après-midi à
paris à l'appel de sos racisme et de la
coordination des étudiants chinois
trois mille personnes ont défilé de la
bastille à la république après avoir
inauguré symboliquement une réplique de
la statue de la démocratie détruites sur
la place et n amène par les chars de
l'armée
parmi les manifestants pierre mauroy
harlem désir
bernard kouchner à la malienne et la
cantatrice barbara hendricks
les rénovateurs réunis à lyon au tour de
michel noir
après les résultats des élections
européennes ils ont revu leurs ambitions
à la baisse mais ils ont maintenu l'idée
de créer un groupe unique de
l'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
véronique saint olive et claude bellec
ont suivi ces travaux deux mois de
débats de discussions d'affrontements de
récupération et rénovateurs décidément
ont la peau dure noir nyon barnier
carignon les autres continuent ils l'ont
dit toute la journée chacun à sa façon
la rénovation
c'est une oeuvre de longue haleine car
contrairement à ce que certains
espéraient contrairement même à ce que
certains redoutaient
aujourd'hui 24 juin nous rénovateurs
nous ne casseront pas l'opposition
nous ne ferons ni coup médiatique ni
coup politique
nous affirmerons tout simplement notre
refus du statut cours
pour philippe seguin l'exercice est
difficile avant-hier il approuvait
jacques chirac dans son refus d'une
fusion des partis de l'opposition
aujourd'hui il signe la motion des
rénovateurs favorable à un groupe unique
à l'assemblée nationale et l
organisation à terme d'une formation
unique dans le grand chambardement de la
recomposition du paysage politique
les rénovateurs s'épuise à conserver
leurs spécificités
ils ont dit aujourd'hui il n'est pas
question pour eux de renier les partis
traditionnels ni a fortiori les chefs
qui les dirigent alors ils se battent
pour faire passer leurs idées
il n'y aura pas d'élections au cours des
trois ans à venir
le temps pour eux de se faire leur place
au soleil et de se ranger le moment venu
derrière celui qui apparaîtra comme le
meilleur leader de l'opposition en marge
de cette réunion ne pourra pas reprocher
à 3 élus rénovateur qui venait de la
mayenne dans un petit avion de ne pas
s'être mouillé à la suite d'une panne de
moteur leur avion s'est posé en
catastrophe sur la saône en plein centre
de lyon une peur que de mal
les trois élus et le pilote s'en sont
sortis avec seulement quelques blessures
82 ans après le premier raid automobile
entre pékin et paris qui ont appris les
mêmes voitures recommencer comme en 1907
litas là c'est le nom de la voiture a
parcouru les vingt-deux mille kilomètres
lentement mais sûrement une précision le
raid est parti de pékin le 24 mars et a
quitté la chine avant les événements
valérie chaillou était elle arrivée ce
matin à paris derniers préparatifs
derniers réglages dans quelques heures
cette voiture itala va tenter de
renouveler son exploit relier pékin à
paris comme en 1907
place tienanmen ce 24 mars les derniers
sourire du peuple chinois l'accompagnent
dans ses premiers maîtres 82 ans après
les téméraires est entièrement différent
et bien plus non cette fois vingt-deux
mille kilomètres et 90 étapes
l'attendent dépassant aussi des pèlerins
comme ces moines bouddhistes
qu'allah malgré sa robustesse ces quatre
tonnes et son équipe technique celle de
la fiat connaît quelques difficultés au
col du soleil et de la lumière c'est la
neige qui est au rendez vous le froid
puis ce sont les routes défoncées où le
bitume est encore inconnue l'armée devra
intervenir avec de l'explosif pour
dégager la voie
dix mille trois cents kilomètres
parcourus encore dix pays a traversée
après la chine le pakistan en iran puis
direction moscou varsovie berlin et
bruxelles sur des routes de plus en plus
fréquentable enfin ce matin après trois
mois de route
la légendaire italien est arrivé à paris
l'équipe italienne a renouvelé l'exploit
du conte borghèse sans trop de problèmes
la panne la plus grave rupture d'un
ressort pas même où premier but en boxe
on vient de l'apprendre le combat que
devait livrer le français christophe
tiozzo quoi attentes à atlantic city
contre l'américain redjil barnes a été
annulée les règles de qualifications de
jo jo n'était pas remplie selon la
commission de boxe du new-jersey nouveau
succès pour eric caritoux cette fois ci
on est passé de la boxe on parle de vélo
donc caritoux a remporté nouvelle fois
le titre de champion de france de
cyclisme professionnel claude ai marre
il est en forme laurent fignon après sa
superbe victoire en italie
c'est le favori de ces championnats de
france c'est d'ailleurs lui qui va
ramener le peloton sur toutes les
échappées sur tout sauf sur la dernière
on y retrouve boyer c'est lui qui la
provoquent dans les 20 derniers
kilomètres
gayant rue et gagne peut lier caritoux
bezos le claire jourdan et l'avenue
fignon et c'est bien de réagir
il démarre tout seul mais ne reviendra
pas cette fois les dix hommes comptent
rapidement 30 secondes 45 secondes puis
une 30 d'avancé sur le peloton à cinq
kilomètres de l'arrivée
on se prépare alors au sprint mais dans
le dernier kilomètre bezos et caritoux
parviennent à s'extraire
bezos l'espoir numéro 1 caritoux le
champion de france en titre caritoux qui
restent jusqu'à 300 mètres de la ligne
dans la roue de vélo
et puis qui démarre irrésistible
au classement final eric caritoux
l'emportent donc et réalise le doublé 2e
laurent bezeau troisième martial gayant
à 14 secondes pour les joueurs et les
parieurs en tout genre le loto le tiercé
le quarté avec mike franquart le tirage
du loto national si vous avez coché le
12 le 14 le 32 33 des 34 38 et le 43
comme numéro complémentaire vous avez
gagné le tiercé à longchamp la
combinaison gagnante 2 4 le 2 et le 12
pour apporte 750 francs dans l'ordre et
150 francs dans un ordre différent pour
5 francs le quarté + 4 2 12 et 5 un
petit rapport 3700 francs et 80 centimes
dans l'ordre dans un ordre différent 462
francs et 60 centimes le trio 42 francs
60 pour 6 francs les pronostics de
pierrette brès pour demain à longchamp
dans le prix j veine 6-2 5-2 2,8 le 3 le
4 le 7 le 12 et le neuf
sauvons les animaux depuis ce matin
depuis hier matin d'ailleurs maintenant
antennes de la spa se sont mobilisés
pour recueillir des fonds qui
permettront de développer des
dispensaires sociaux pour ceux qui n'ont
pas les moyens de faire soigner leurs
bêtes
après la météo lionel caleçon à fera à
nouveau le point sur cette opération
je rappelle que vous pouvez téléphoner
aux 47 30 33 33 16 1 devant si vous
habitez la province vous tapez sur votre
minitel 36 15 codes à 2 pour vous
procurer le jeu de société sauvons les
animaux qui servira à financer les
dispensaires dans quelques instants josé
blanc la pierre pour le temps qu'il fera
demain vous rendez vous êtes information
dimanche à 13h et 20h avec daniel
bilalian et à demain soir
bonne fin de soirée